I'll just have to ask you to scroll
great
so I'll just go ahead then
um so the title is a predictive model
for post chemotherapy neurodegeneration
Based on rnac data
and next slide
so brain fog is one of the most commonly
reported side effects of
chemotherapeutic treatments so there's
Cici that's chemotherapy induced that
should be induced sorry cognitive
impairment there's also
chemotherapy-induced peripheral
neuropathy and they're two different
things but they're sort of related the
first is
characterized by cognitive impairment so
issues with memory
um issues completing various tasks and
then peripheral neuropathy neuropathy
um is characterized by pain generally so
what's surprising is that Cici involves
the central nervous system so the
blood-brain barrier should be filtering
out chemotherapeutic agents generally
from having an effect on those neurons
whereas peripheral neuropathy is more
understandable given that those neurons
should be directly in contact with the
chemotherapeutic agent but you see the
death of neurons in both cases so it
implies that there might be an indirect
mechanism
and
regarding the indirect mechanism as well
it makes it difficult to study
chemotherapy-induced cognitive
impairment because it involves the
central nervous system
so for all of those reasons what you
need is a diagnostic technique that is
non-invasive and so that's where the
rnac data comes in
yeah I think this says everything I was
just saying so
the
aim of this project then is to try and
build a machine learning model which can
predict whether or not a patient has had
a chemotherapeutic agent and then use
that model to try and identify
genes that are related to
neurodegeneration in order to try and
build another model which can predict
neurodegeneration in the case of
patients who
've been exposed to a chemotherapeutic
agent
yep I think that's what that says
so the proposed methodology is use
rna-seq data from patients who retreated
with the chemotherapeutic drug
um and use it to train a random Forest
classifier so the classifier would just
look at basically pre and posts uh
treatment with the chemotherapeutic drug
the data set that I use actually had
samples from patients before they were
treated and samples afterwards
so it basically would just look it would
basically just classify the sample as
pre and post
and then scanning the available
literature I would look for a list of
genes which have been implicated in
neurodegeneration
otherwise and then look at the future
importance of those genes in my model to
see whether
the model basically use them to
predict
whether the person had been treated with
the chemotherapeutic agent or not
sorry I haven't looked at these slides
since yesterday so I'm kind of liking
what they do all right so everything
else is in the actual notebook
foreign
so just a lot of data cleaning
um in the original data set there were
samples from patients
before they were treated samples during
treatment and then afterwards so all I
did was just filter out the
sort of the intermediate group and just
create a list of paired samples so
before treatment and then after 90 days
of treatment
it's
yep
and scroll
yep just cleaning the data
should really collapse a lot of these
and labels
all right and then finally the model
itself so the model was surprisingly
accurate it did a good job actually it
it correctly identified the sample
around 70 of the time
um and so then I just checked different
train test splits
and so I found surprisingly that with
the 40s but it was up to 85 accurate
and so that's the split that I used
going forward
and so then I looked at feature
importance
oh and you can see the confusion Matrix
it just
yeah it's all fairly intuitive
so then future importance I basically
took the top 20 features as far as
importance goes and then ran basically a
quick literature review on them to see
if they had been implicated in no
degeneration
and surprisingly about 10 of them were
and so then what I tried to do using the
other literature sources that I had
found was basically
compile a list of other genes that
should be involved in neurodegeneration
and look for them in this data set
which unfortunately did not work and the
reason why is because this data set uses
there are no Gene names it's actually
probe IDs and there isn't a one-to-one
correspondence between the name and the
probe ID
so for like one of the genes there's 10
different probes that corresponds to it
and unfortunately none of them were in
the data set so that's something that I
would improve on
oh
um there was one more
there was yeah
and so what I did was I basically
selected for those features and tried to
improve the accuracy of the model
foreign
so using 10 features out of 20 000 the
model actually became more accurate
and so
just scroll down a bit
yep and the false positive rate is
actually lower
thank you all right is that it
um and so there's a
small part down below
yeah so the point of doing all this was
just to identify uh usefulness of genes
that might be used to
create the model that actually
predicts neurodegeneration but for that
you would need labeled data which
at our time finding